bienvenidos en este vídeo quiero
discutir algunas cosas acerca de
funciones pares
vamos a ponerlo acá funciones
párese
que van a estar del lado izquierdo de su
pantalla y también de funciones impares
que van a estar de este lado del lado
derecho funciones impares
bien antes de dar una definición formal
quiero dar algunos ejemplos gráficos
porque creo que además eso va a servir
para que las puedan reconocer más
fácilmente y de hecho va a motivar la
definición de una función padre así que
déjenme voy a dibujar mis ejes
coordinados por aquí hasta mi eje x
y mi eje
michelle y el eje x está un poco seco
pero bueno
y vamos a considerar que es una función
de x así que voy a dibujar aquí o voy a
graficar la función fx igual a x al
cuadrado y veamos qué es eso pues es una
parábola es una parábola
webber esto tiene que ser
ahí está más o menos el punto es que
esta función tiene cierta simetría
alrededor del eje y es decir en lo que
está del lado derecho del eje y es un
reflejo de lo que está del lado
izquierdo
por ejemplo tomemos un valor de x
positivo digamos x igual a 2 x igualados
entonces
fx es 2 al cuadrado que sería 4 en esta
función en particular así que si me
muevo para acá en el bng o al menos 2
el valor que toma la función debe ser
también 4
ok y espero que eso lo vean fácilmente
si tiene la función cierta simetría
alrededor del eje y entonces para
cualquier número positivo su reflejo va
a ser el mismo número negativo pero el
valor de la función no camps de hecho
esta va a ser la propiedad que defina a
las funciones pares voy a decir que una
función es par
función par
sí solo si lo voy a poner aquí abajo
para no invadir el lado de los impares
si solos y fx es igual a efe de menos x
esa es la definición formal de una
función parc y tengan cuidado porque
esto no tiene nada que ver con los
números pares y con los o con los
números impares esto simplemente es un
nombre por ejemplo
por ejemplo en este caso tengo que efe
de dos estados es igual a efe de menos 2
gay las dos valen 4 por lo tanto esta es
una función par bien vamos a darles
algunos ejemplos más vamos a graficar
algunas otras cosas voy a graficar
algunas funciones que tienen
comportamientos medio locochones para
que se den una idea de qué tan generales
pueden ser las funciones pares por
ejemplo podría ser que la función
hiciera algo así digamos aquí va a ser
así la función se supone que todo lo que
está del lado derecho del eje ya es un
reflejo de lo que está del lado
izquierdo así que si no me salen muy
bien las cosas por favor usen su
imaginación pero bueno entonces aquí
para llegar acá la función
y aquí va a saltar va a saltar para acá
aquí va a ser algo así y de repente no
sé igual y hace algo así cuando llega a
este punto la función falta
y hace algo así
recuerden se supone que esto está
reflejado así que si yo reflejo esto
sobre el eje y obtengo el lado izquierdo
pero bueno veamos por ejemplo podría
fijarme en el valor de este punto
digamos que estoy aquí es 3 y la función
aquí vale 5
esto es
efe 3 y estoy diciendo que vale 5
entonces menos 3 estaría por acá
en los tres estaría por acá y la función
ahí vale cinco también por lo tanto esta
función también es par porque está
reflejada el lado derecho es el reflejo
del lado izquierdo no también podría ser
algo del tipo del tipo trigonométrico
por ejemplo la función coseno es par
pero en sí podría ser cualquier cosa que
tuviera esta forma
así quizás
y así esto sería la gráfica de una
función para las gráficas de una función
par básicamente si tomas una hoja de
papel y la doblas a la mitad si la
doblas sobre el eje y debe sobreponerse
el lado izquierdo en la gráfica con el
lado derecho eso es lo que me dice la
definición de función parte bien vamos
ahora con las funciones impares voy a
comenzar con lo que yo creo sería el
ejemplo clásico de una función impar
quizás podríamos decir que este era el
ejemplo clásico de una función par y
este quizá sea el ejemplo clásico de una
función impar así que de nuevo tengo mis
ejes xy james
y ahora lo que quiero hacer es
considerar la función
la función fx es igual a x al cubo
y yo creo que ustedes ya conocen la
gráfica pero por si no lo voy a dibujar
la gráfica se ve algo así
espero que esté suficientemente
simétrica en este caso ya no es cierto
que si reflejo la gráfica sobre el eje y
obtengo la otra mitad la gráfica si
reflejo esta rama lo que está del lado
derecho del eje y sobre el eje y
obtendría algo así más o menos
y esto no es igual al resto de la
gráfica lo que tengo que hacer ahora es
primero reflejar alrededor del eje y y
después reflejar alrededor del eje x o
podría hacerlo al revés primero es
reflejar alrededor del eje x y después
reflejar alrededor del eje y cualquiera
de las dos cosas me produciría el mismo
resultado y veamos ahora qué pasa si me
tomo de nuevo mi valor todos me tomo el
valor 2
cuánto vale cede 2 pues vale 82 al cubo
es 8 pero si ahora me voy al menos dos
menos dos cuánto creen que valga
efe de menos dos menos dos al cubo ya no
es ocho si no es menos ocho
- 8 así que ahora no es cierto que ese 2
sea igual a efe de menos 2 pero sí es
cierto sí es cierto que f de 2 es igual
a menos
efe de menos 2
si ven efe de dos era simplemente ocho y
- efe - dos sería menos
efe de menos dos que es menos ocho los
menos se cancelan y tara 8 es igual a 8
así que esto va a ser lo que nos va a
servir para definir las funciones
impares
voy a estar tratando con una función
impar
función
sí solo sí
para todo x f x
por lo tanto fx es igual a menos
efe de menos x o quizás también lo hayan
visto o lo vean como si multiplico esto
por menos podría escribirlo como menos
fx es igual a efe de menos x cualquiera
de estas dos cosas son la misma pero
bueno vamos a ver más ejemplos para ver
el comportamiento de estos bichos
de nuevo james
x
x james y ahora consideremos una función
vamos a hacer una que haga algo raro
vamos a suponer que la función hace algo
así
por aquí llega en el 0 en el 0 la
función tiene que valer 0
por qué pase eso se los dejo como reto
personal sale luego luego de la
definición de función impar cualquier
función impar en el cero tiene que valer
cero pero bueno como podría completar
esta gráfica para que sea una función
impar pues reflejó esto a lo largo del
eje x o a lo largo el eje y y después a
lo largo del otro eje si hice primero el
eje y entonces después el eje x hice
primero el eje x después el eje y
obtendría algo más o menos así
espero que se entienda que se vea noten
que si esto es un valor y esto es un
número positivo y esto es cda
estoy aquí está esta altura entonces en
menos
en menos
este punto de aquí que sería efe de
menos a
está a la misma distancia del eje x que
excede a la distancia que hay de este
punto al eje x o de este punto al origen
es la misma que la que hay de este punto
al eje x o de este punto al origen
la distancia es igual claramente los
valores no son iguales
pero ver veamos un último ejemplo de
función impar que de hecho es un ejemplo
bastante padre porque es un ejemplo
bastante bastante sencillo lo voy tengo
mi eje x en mi calle y la función que
voy a graficar ahora es simplemente la
función de igual a equis
y la función identidad se ve algo así y
fíjense qué sucede si reflejo primero
alrededor del eje y obtengo
algo así y esto no es el resto de la
gráfica ahora tengo que reflejar sobre
el eje x y en ese caso si obtendría esto
que es el cacho que me faltaba en mi
gráfica así que esta también es una
función impar los voy a dejar viendo
algunos ejemplos de funciones que no son
ni padres ni impares ok
vamos a ver
vamos a pensar en algo como sigue de
nuevo
y ahora vamos a imaginar que tenemos una
parábola pero que la parábola tiene
vértice por acá entonces quizás estén
diciendo bueno esto es una función par
porque hay una cierta simetría alrededor
de esa línea pero ese no es el eje y el
eje ya está acá así que en sí no es
cierto que fx sea igual a efe de menos x
esto no se cumple ok
porque esto asimetría no es alrededor
del eje y así que esto es un ejemplo de
una función que no estar ni impar no es
impar
o también podríamos pensar en algo así
una vez
eje x
y vamos a pensar en la función fx es
igual a x al cubo más 1 y esta función
es la misma función que quizá el cubo
solo que levantada una unidad entonces
su gráfica se ve algo así
su gráfica se va a ver algo así
que este punto de aquí sería el punto 1
ahora esta función tampoco es parte ni
es impar para ver que no es impar
fíjense si reflejara esto alrededor del
eje y obtendría una curva que se vería
algo así y al reflejar esto ahora sobre
el eje x obtendría algo así
así que no coinciden las gráficas esta
gráfica que debería ser para que fuera
una función impar así que esto tampoco
es una función impar les dejo también de
acertijo pensar en cuál es la única
función que es par e impar
pero bueno
quiero dejar algo claro muy rápidamente
esta función no fue para nin part porque
este reflejo no coincida con este en
este caso es perfectamente aceptable